[Music]
in mystery solver news submitted by Sam
loves JK thank you and we love Sam a
psychic detective reveals how he helps
officers solve murder cases you know
this always baffled me when our city
police departments rely on psychic
detectives because you know when they
catch criminals and then they take from
the court like what did they use the
psychics evidence like like your honor
this you know it's the Age of Aquarius
and the suspect was you know the Leo
like you know and it was a half moon
that night so all the signs were right
did you ever see TV shows like well it's
like a TV show where this dude he can
memorize [ __ ] and so photographic memory
yeah that thank you he has a
photographic memory and he pretends that
he's a psychic but he just leads the
Cubs to actual evidence - can you just
say I have pornographic memory I cream
em right yeah I'm smartest [ __ ] listen
to me Sherlock Holmes or what his dad
was a cop and his friend helps them
because they're [ __ ] these cops are
stupid Poron oh yeah don't believe me
when I do that yeah you'll do that [ __ ]
and then he'll look at like actual check
the shed outside but this guy his name
is troy Griffin he claims he's been
hired by several police departments to
get me includes on cold cases and he
apparently has made media appearances
for the visions that he gets when he
handles photos of victims or crimes so
Vice had a phone interview with him and
for those what do you think [ __ ] but
what if it were it's working cuz like
police departments are seeking him out
they're like we can't solve this case we
need help
what Police Department is really hiring
I don't know is he just saying like he's
getting hired by police departments well
he's saying that 90% of his cases come
from families that are like hoping that
he can help them not really oh yeah he
says that he's worked on 30 cases and he
works on 30 cases a year so it's pretty
regular work
yeah so he's saying that he prefers to
be called an intuitive medium and
psychic investigator that he doesn't
like the reputation of a psychic like he
doesn't use crystal balls or tarot cards
oh he's not that kind Gabriel but he
does dress in a purple garb he does
believe in that so then what are his
methods then and he looks like Lord
Varys
yeah I thought you saying that he
learned of his gifts yeah when he was 12
yeah x-ray vision staring at girls Oh
[ __ ] his sister good no he would have
these visions and they he would just
shrug them off as just deja vu until he
was in his 40s and he met another
psychic and that she instantly knew of
his gift and she asked him what he
thought about a missing persons case and
that he felt that the girl had been hit
with a pipe and then week later they
found out that he was correct and so he
decided that this was his life's calling
that's crazy
what a lucky guy how come he can't do
that [ __ ] with the lottery but maybe he
could all the lottery numbers are but
maybe it's only for good or like it's
only for trauma it's for your own person
numbers isn't his thing what if I won
the lottery Julia mm-hmm
and I decided to donate all the money
took [ __ ] orphanage that would be a
future I said to orphan [ __ ] - oh
yeah
is that a fortune I guess future year
first future yeah I think his psychic
abilities is like and otherwise already
happen right so he's like picking up on
these [ __ ] spirits like the energy in
the earth it's not future [ __ ] can see
the future
yeah I wish I had the future [ __ ] no
that's a good [ __ ] why not ignorance is
bliss you don't want to know your future
yell but we could change it we could
change it we could fix it escape destiny
I think you can outrun destiny a little
bit host a UFC oh my Goldberg yeah he
looks like he just wrote a New York
Times bestseller and that picture is on
the corner of his book next to the
[ __ ] bar cold his wife and two dogs
so he works with families from all over
the world they contact him for help he
says that he asks for a photo of the
victim and their last known location
he'll go to that location and he'll let
his intuition guide him aka Google yeah
he's like I want your photograph I want
your name and I want details of the
murder case very specific details yeah
thank you if he goes and he doesn't feel
like a connection or anything then he
won't take the case any further because
he doesn't want to give families false
hope what if he feels the tingling in
his balls he'll take your money I'll
take the case yeah and I'll solve it for
you you get his strongest visions when
he's travelling and that he'll start to
sweat and he get strong and anxiety and
he has to figure out like what all that
means so in his world like everywhere he
goes he senses spirits or like what does
he do he's just driving he's like yeah
that damn that kind of sucks
terrible he's like oh I don't like
Missouri there's a lot of bad [ __ ] there
but like you know he could only stay in
his safe zones that he's familiar with I
really don't know how his thing works
I want to know and that 40 year old
woman saved his life just before that if
he didn't know he was a psychic he'd
probably need to get prescriptions for
all his [ __ ] hallucination there well
he was 40 when he saw her but yeah like
if I hadn't these crazy-ass feelings of
people getting hit in the head at the
pie pie pie boy [ __ ] he's on
medication cats for tea and she's like
you're a wizard Harry or was
how's that work
you're a psychic Troy was she like his
psychic master that kind of helped him
groom him into this world or he was just
saying that he was did he do it in the
montage while she's in the background
like yes hard yeah it's like a training
sequence like you can't pick up the [ __ ]
and fall with his brain uh-huh just do
it one more time yeah to an original
song what was he doing before this if
you want to sell the crime you gotta use
your mind right there's the New Jersey
psychic right there's the do my favorite
shoot is uh what the [ __ ] is it it's
like a pet psychic one he talks to cats
or some [ __ ] yeah his name's like some
it sounds like a fake name his name's
like Sebastian bojay oh the guy it's
like a punchable you know people have
punchable faces he hasn't punchable man
does he have this stupid haircut and yes
the cat whisperer he's a psychic and
what's it suicide Jackson galaxy
that guy Kitty ball thing that was that
yeah he gave a speech and I laughed
through it oh my god he looks so
interesting uh I think I mean any clique
any of them it's Jackson galaxy if
anyone in the history of time and space
has ever looked like a magician this is
that man he looks like he works in Vegas
yeah bald with the [ __ ] chin spot the
strip yeah or in old Vegas palms he's
doing a magic show you see easy the cats
there's a cat psychic them so easy like
that so he's like Caesar cat behaviorist
yeah shut up
no but there's like a show called
Hollywood medium or something and there
and it's like this like very thin
guy who's blonde he's like 20 or
something he goes all these Hollywood
celebs homes and reads their the dead or
whatever it's all he doesn't cut was the
one that we were watching and we saw her
billboard that she was gonna go visit
that Indian casino was it New Jersey
psychic or something yeah I like those
shows like I like such trash TV but yeah
I love it dude it's like damn this is
this is real America right here that
you're talking about yes yes Wow he's
like this like southern like very
feminine guy you like think he'd be
really nice no dare you we're trying to
share this man to say let her say it he
looks clean cut there you go yeah that's
better
he looks like he beats his girlfriend's
he looks like he doesn't have a
girlfriend he looks like [ __ ]
policías brother that's true she did I'm
disappointed in you because he cheated
the Julia better than crazy over it okay
I like her house it's it's super Italian
but not like Italy Italian it's like
American Italian like like the Guido
style
yeah Olive Garden house it's very
interesting
it's like Sopranos I don't have a
picture at home but this is a Long
Island yeah oh that one Long Island
medium dude you could just take this out
and put in Dance Moms and I'd buy it too
I'm like that's probably Dance Moms as
well they all have that like [ __ ]
hairdo with the bangs and then the yeah
they got like a tennessee beehive
haircut i mean she's like do you want
the special like you know that kind of
[ __ ] oh yeah that would just be married
like Emperor's New Groove when they went
into that restaurant in the waitress
oh yeah right right you don't know what
she's talking about oh watch cartoons I
was trying to be polite you never back
[Music]
I don't watch cartoon movies I will say
I but I watched like Looney Tunes and
Merrie Melodies on that but I don't see
how Merrie Melodies like the Chuck Chuck
Jones stuff I love John yeah yeah yeah
yeah so anyway so this dude
Troy his response to the hairs is quote
for people who don't think I should be
meddling what I predict you're gay
childish like that you know take control
to continuing what it comes down to is I
come with good intentions and feel like
I'm making a difference I've never been
to a psychic development class I don't
go to seances that's too dark for me I'm
not going to give any false hope I'm
just telling what comes to or through me
my job is to help people moving just
sexual monologue situation where that
family will never find closure but if I
can come in and even help try to move
forward I will do it you know what's
gonna happen right someone close to us
he's kind of [ __ ] dive is gonna be an
unsolved mystery we're gonna call upon
the powers and he's gonna say no you
guys laugh you know you made fun of me
but oh wait you read the [ __ ] wrong what
is it he says I [ __ ] love [ __ ]
money
[Music]